let's go to Miguel from Central Florida
Miguel from Central Florida Welcome to
the David packman show what can I do for
you today
hi David how does my mic sound it sounds
beautiful
oh perfect uh I wanted to ask uh being
someone that's coming from Central
Florida I've obviously seen kind of the
rise of the the santis and a lot of the
rides at the right wing culture War
issues yep so I was wondering
uh considering DeSantis expanded his
lead in
Florida this time around to what extent
would you place the blame on the local
Florida Democratic party or you could
even translate it to the national issue
as well how much would you kind of
assign the blame to the Democratic party
for not being able to effectively
counter the kind of right wing uh
messaging that has dominated the media
almost since Trump has won the election
there's a couple different things here
part of this is timing and what I mean
by that is I think that if the DeSantis
re-election if in Florida were November
2023 rather than November 2022 I don't
think DeSantis wins by 19. now he
probably still wins but the reason I say
he doesn't win by 19 is since November
the tide really has turned on a lot of
this culture War stuff that DeSantis ran
his campaign on so I think part of part
of it was timing and timing was the
reason DeSantis expanded uh his margin
of Victory now can we blame Democrats to
some degree sure you almost always can
right like you can almost always do
something to lose by less even if you're
going to lose than if you do nothing at
all I don't know enough about the
internal dynamics of the Florida what's
going on in Florida to be able to
specifically lay blame but I think big
picture big picture there was like a
peak in the culture War stuff right
around November 2022 which did help some
Republicans like the santis and had
those elections been held six months
later like now I think the results would
have been at least slightly different
yeah no I could definitely see that
unfortunately I'd say that the the
ground game for the Florida Democratic
party is I'd say almost non-existent
here is that right definitely see how uh
no it was uh I mean back during the
election I would have people knocking on
my door handing out the Santa's
pamphlets and I live in a blue County
you know and I I didn't get a single
Democratic person knock on my door
although I will say that it was mostly
the unions that were out here uh trying
to campaign for candidates interesting
but I guess that would be a conversation
for another day if anything yeah Nicole
thank you so much there is Miguel from
Central Florida we're going to take the
quickest of breaks and then we're gonna
come right back here and hear from more
of you okay so if you're holding on to
talk to me just hold on a little bit
longer sometimes it can be tough to
maintain an emotional connection with
your significant other you might work in
different places at different times
there might be a kid in the way it can
be hard to find time for date nights
especially because kids demand so much
attention which is why I love our
sponsor paired which is the app for
couples the app will prompt you with a
daily question or a game or a guided
conversation all designed by Leading
psychologists and the point is to just
have a deeper connection with your
partner boost intimacy build a deeper
knowledge of one another my girlfriend
and I will use the prompts on paired
throughout the day to stay connected for
instance we answered a prompt about what
we remember most from the early days of
the relationship it really helps us
learn new things and there can be funny
moments as well an independent study
found that couples using paired saw 36
percent increase in the quality of their
relationship and giving a paired
subscription as a gift is also a really
great idea you can try it free for seven
days and get 25 off a subscription go to
pair.com Pacman the link is in the
description